You're here for a reason, you're here not for this show ...
No, no, no, no.
You're here to learn Swedish.
I'm here because I love Ingmar Bergman films.
And after seeing
all the films
I thought, well, I have to go and learn the language because it's so ...
The melody and you know, it's very: «Å, jaha, jaha, jättebra»!
It's just
It just made me feel really joyful. It still does!
And now I'm studying, and I love to study Swedish!
How long have you been studying now?
Three weeks now.
But this weekn
is the last week.
You came from jazz.
Yeah. I still am there.
Yeah, you're still there. But then you have this, let's call it a detour, to Eurovision Song Contest.
It's my prostitution!
You were quite clear about that when when you called it fast food music.
What do you mean by that?
You know nowadays, I think maybe I was too
fundamentalist, you know, maybe too extreme. Because Eurovision ...
My opinion is that it's not really about music. You know, it's about the show.
You know, it's a show to make people enjoy the all the new technology the new
sound of the things, you know.
What was the first thought that went through your head when they
announced you as the winner of the international competition?
My first thought was «OH MY GOD»!
But in Portuguese, yeah.
No, my first thought, you know, we we were far from the stage and the stage had a lot of stairs
How do you say «stairs»? «Trapper».
So I was very ill back then and for me, it was very difficult for me to go up stairs.
So I was really nervous about that. I got super tired.
So I was like, «oh no, I won and now I'm gonna have to climb all those stairs»!
That was honestly my first ... I think if you really watched it carefully at that moment
I think you can tell by my face that I'm like, «oh no»!
Yeah, I got really tired
just going up the four stairs, you know. Four stairs!
I mean, back then you had this serious heart condition.
Yeah.
And was this was this the way you could notice that you got
easily tired?
If the heart doesn't function, anything else in the body doesn't really function.
So I got tired, you know, I had a lot of liquid retention also.
Yeah. A lot of liquid. You know, I had like 25 kilos of
liquid in my body.
I had a stomach like this, like an old beer guy.
Was this during the Eurosong?
Yeah, I had ... If you look I was wearing a very large shirt, so it you couldn't notice. A black shirt.
But if you look carefully you can see that there's something there, you know. But now I play football
two hours a week!
And I run. I can do anything now!
The reason that you could, if I understand right here, the reason that you could go through with the whole Eurosong thing
was ... You owe parts of that to your sister because ...
Parts of that? Almost all of it! My sister wrote the song.
Yeah, the song.
Yeah, she stepped in for me in the rehearsals for a week.
But was that ... I mean, when you win a victory like that
It's a whole year that is sort of a bit like being a part of a big circus.
Was there like a moment when you realizes «I can't be a part of the circus»?
I can't be ... I'm not fit for this.
Yeah, that moment happened before because they have ... before Eurovision, as you must know, they have a lot of parties ...
You know, Eurovision pre-party and I couldn't do it physically, but I didn't want to do it either, you know.
Because they had it in clubs, you know.
I don't really like clubs and it's a whole world where there's a lot of things that I just don't identify with.
You know, so from the beginning I was a bit apart from everything until the end, you know.
Right after I won there was a lot of things to do like the winners should do
and
It's not that I'm against it. It's just that I don't identify with it.
You had a long period, I don't know how long it was, but you were waiting.
Six months.
What were you doing?
I was waiting. Waiting for a transplant.
Could you could you write songs? Could you work?
Are there songs on your album that are from that period?
It would be very romantic to say that I wrote
a lot of songs in my very hard period of my life!
The reality really is that I just watched series on Netflix. I was so depressed, you know.
Well, I also
saw a lot of Ingmar Bergman films. Roy Andersson films. «En kärlekshistoria».
But no, I didn't write songs
and then after I wrote a couple of songs that that are gonna be in my next album.
The first song, actually, is really about that experience and it's a sort of a
look at the catharsis moment and it's actually separated from the rest of the album
so you have the first song which is like the catharsis of that moment and then afterwards the album really begins and it's like a
rebirth album, you know.
And that's where you are now?
That's where I am now.
How was it to go on stage for the first time as ...
With a new heart?
It's funny that you ask that. The first time I did it in a bar where I play often in Portugal, but
I didn't have any strength in my legs, you know, because I'd been
laying down ... How do you say?
Bedridden.
That's okay in three weeks, that's not one of the first words you learn anyway!
Yeah, so had a laid down for so long. I didn't have the muscles, you know. So I remember trying to sing and
my voice just rambled all over because I don't know why, I didn't have the strength in my voice
I didn't have the strength anyway
And I was so frustrated singing a song that I just jumped and did this and I fell on stage, you know.
I fell on stage!
It was a bar, you know, but I fell and I'm like «I should leave», you know.
I was so sad and then little by little
I began singing
well. Better.
And now ... I don't think it's there yet, but it's getting there. The voice, you know.
But you feel okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah! Really well!
But do you know whose heart you got?
No, no, no, no!
That's impossible to know, you know, and I wouldn't wanna know.
I just feel fine. Who cares whose it is, you know.
But anyway, it's a great heart, isn't it?
Yes, yes, yes. Absolutely.
I'm so amazed that you're here tonight. I'm so glad you're here tonight. And
we're gonna have some other guests on.
And later on you're gonna sing for us as well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hope you enjoyed the clip! For more interesting conversations, please hit subscribe.